in today's eye on money we are talking
about
taxes unfortunately the filing deadline
was extended though to may 17
this year thanks to the american rescue
plan act the irs
has already processed more than 105
million tax returns
and given out more than 77 million
refunds
the average refund is 2 870
here with some tax season advice is cbs
news business
analyst jill schlesinger jill good
morning
this is not my favorite time of the year
[Laughter]
but here's the first question if someone
collected unemployment benefits if you
received a stimulus check
is that taxable income
so there's a really interesting change
for this tax year for unemployment
benefits which are
usually taxable if you earn less than a
hundred fifty thousand dollars last year
ten thousand two hundred dollars of
unemployment benefits are not taxable to
you and that's a big deal
uh twenty thousand four hundred if you
both got it as a married couple
now the stimulus checks whatever you
receive
that is not taxable at all so for those
who receive that emergency assistance
the tax situation should be a lot better
than you probably thought
six months ago all right that's good
news but there's a lot of confusing
elements this year particularly
here's a question that that stumps me if
someone worked remotely
in another state if your office is in
one state you work remotely from another
do you pay taxes in in that state
oh this is so confusing and i am sorry i
contacted the great folks at the aicpa
big organization of cpas and they say
this comes down to you counting the
number of days
where you worked and what you're going
to have to do
is find out what the rules are in the
local jurisdiction
as well as in your usual place of
domicile i know if your head is spinning
right now
you may want to contact a cpa or a tax
preparer to help you out
you know in some cases anthony it could
be good news you might have worked in a
place with a lower tax rate so
it is worth going through the process
all right
we were given obviously the deadline was
pushed back to may 17th that's good news
but if you still haven't gotten your act
together can you file for an extension
you can but get your act together you
know those numbers that you put up in
the beginning
are very instructive you know about 85
percent of tax filers they receive
refunds and don't you want that money
that's thousands of dollars
but yes if you have a problem you can
absolutely
positively file for an extension it's
form 4868
and that will give you an extension
until october 15th the extension comes
with a caveat and that is
if you think you owe taxes you've got to
pay those taxes
now by the 17th whatever you think you
owe the actual filing can take place
by october 15th one other thing if you
plan on making a
roth ira or an ira contribution you
don't delay that
that deadline is may 17th you even if
you file for an extension so
get that money in so you can start
saving more for retirement but jill what
if you
just can't afford to pay your taxes
right now what are the options do you
throw yourself on the mercy of the court
well you know the irs has plenty of
options
and that's really good news because
there's an option to actually say give
me a little help for
say four months that's a short term plan
there's a longer term
installment plan there's also a way that
you could actually pay taxes with a
credit card i don't
suggest that because there are fees
associated but you probably can get
yourself
on a plan that's pretty easy at irs.gov
there's a lot of options there and
they're not really so expensive so i
encourage you to do that one thing also
never hide from the irs because even
though they've been underfunded for the
last 20 years
they tend to find you they will get you
and yeah you don't want the irs coming
after you and again filing deadline may
17th a week from monday
thanks jill